Zimbabwe has suspended the hunting of
lions leopards and elephants in an area
were aligned that popular with tourists
was killed as follows an international
outcry after an American trophy hunter
killed Cecil the lion after allegedly
luring him out of a national park we
spoke earlier to nine expert Gareth
Patterson who's in Iassogna in South
Africa the lion had been rehabilitating
back to the wild was also lured out of a
protected area and killed I've never
actually seen such a public outpouring
like there has been with the whole issue
of of this lion obsessed and and it
really just illustrates the power of the
internet I mean when my male lion Batson
was killed 24 years ago yes I mean it
got a lot of attention all over the
world but back in those days we didn't
have the internet so it really has been
quite explosive and and really
heartening you know that the public are
responding like they are Patton was one
of the last Adamson Lions who I rescued
and rehabilitated back into the wild
after the death of after the murder of
the legendary lion man George Adamson
and and I we rehabilitated him and his
two sisters back into the wild and when
he was just over three years old he was
like like Pike's vessel he was lured by
artificial means out of the safety of
the park that he was in and yeah and he
was lured and they were waiting for him
and he was shot dead so I mean there's
enormous parallels chilling actually
parallels between the death of a teen 24
years ago and with this recent situation
in Zimbabwe I don't forget that this
sort of thing is happening all the time
it's not just back in 24 years ago and
fess all the lion in Zimbabwe as a
present situation I mean this is common
we're probably losing about 900 Lions a
year predominantly when it comes to
trophy hunting of lions in Africa about
60% of all
the liens that are being killed our
United States trophy hunters and 40% is
approximately 40% of our people from
from Europe and like I said you know
they're probably losing about nine
hundred to a thousand Lions a year and
obviously you know these trophy hunters
what they want is male lions with the
biggest mane you know full-grown adult
male lions and what a lot of people
don't realize is that once a pride male
has been shot from from his pride then
an actual cycle happens whereupon a new
male will come into the pride or new new
males will move into the pride and they
will they will kill the previous pride
lions Cubs so it's not just when a
hunter kills one male line it's not just
one lion that died as many as 14 to 15
or more lions died because the Cubs are
killed so with this unnatural killing of
pride male it actually accumulates into
a killing of of a hell of a lot more
Lions than one